- Hello and welcome to the LearnStorm
growth mindset live stream.
I'm Rachel, a senior
communications manager
at Khan Academy, and I am
so excited to welcome you
to the Khan Academy offices
here in sunny California.
Today's live stream is
gonna be about 60 minutes,
and we're gonna split
it up into two parts.
Up first, we're gonna cover
the LearnStorm program,
what it's all about, and what
it can do for your classroom.
Next, we'll turn our attention
to our fabulous panel
to answer your questions
about growth mindset.
But first, a few tips.
If you have any questions
about growth mindset
or LearnStorm please type
your questions and comments,
and our helpful moderators
will answer your questions.
For those who are trying
to view by YouTube,
I'm really sorry, we're having
some technical problems,
so we're just on Facebook for the moment,
but our questions might be
asked to our panel later on.
I also very much recommend
that you maximize your screen.
We'll be going through a few of
the growth mindset activities,
and you'll definitely want
to see them in full effect.
And lastly, if you can't stay
for the full live stream,
we'll miss you, but don't
worry, we'll record it,
and we'll send out the
recording later on this week.
I have three amazing guests with me today
that I'll introduce in just a few moments.
But first let me share with
you a little about LearnStorm.
LearnStorm is Khan Academy's
free back-to-school program.
It gives teachers a powerful way
to jumpstart the school year.
By combining mindset
activities and skills practice
across subjects, LearnStorm
motivates classrooms
and builds students' confidence.
And yes, you can still
sign up for LearnStorm
through October, so hop to
it if you haven't already.
There's also some time to
win some awesome prizes.
This year all across the US,
teachers and their students
can sign up for LearnStorm.
LearnStorm and Khan Academy
are free, and always will be.
LearnStorm was possible thanks to
the awesome support of MathWorks,
so thank you MathWorks.
LearnStorm can be implemented
flexibly by teachers
as in-class practice, for
homework, or for both,
but in order to get the
most out of LearnStorm
please follow these steps.
One, sign up and assign.
Two, master skills.
Three, build mindsets.
And four, celebrate progress.
Of course, in order to even participate
you must sign up for Khan Academy
by going to khanacademy.org,
and enroll in LearnStorm
from your coach dashboard.
Once you have your account all set up
with your class and students,
teachers can assign all
the content available
on Khan Academy, including
grammar, history, biology.
Not just math.
In addition to core K through 12 subjects,
LearnStorm includes
access to Khan AP lessons
created by former AP teachers
and AP exam reviewers
covering subjects like
AP physics, AP calculus,
AP government and politics, and more.
And then don't forget to enroll
your class in LearnStorm.
Next, it's time for your
students to master skills.
Regardless of the way your teachers decide
to implement LearnStorm,
teachers can track student participation,
get real-time insight when
someone is struggling.
This enables teachers to spend more time
differentiating instruction
and providing targeted help
with learners of all levels.
This picture is of Ms. Kotto
of Wastsonville, California.
She participated in LearnStorm last year,
and you can hear all about her experience
on our website at
learnstorm.khanacademy.org.
Thirdly, the topic of
the hour, growth mindset.
This year, based on feedback
from teachers who used
activities last year,
we have not one, but two
curriculums based on age group.
In the elementary/middle
school curriculum students have
seven activities to learn
alongside this brain character,
Thinky Pinky and his friends.
We'll scroll through one of
these awesome activities now,
which were created in
partnership with PERTS,
a standard research center.
Each activity has articles, videos,
and these are essential reflection points
where students can really take a moment
to internalize and apply
these concepts to their lives.
In the high school curriculum,
students have new lessons on belonging
and will learn through
testimonials and case studies.
We also have focus on highlighting people
from many different backgrounds
and diverse experiences
so students can learn from a
full spectrum of experiences.
We've also made a
comprehensive teacher guide
and lesson plans that
include bell ringers,
class discussions, sample
communications to parents.
You can assign all of these
growth mindset activities
by clicking assign in the
upper right-hand corner.
And as students complete activities
they develop learning
strategies and build confidence
to overcome challenges in
the classroom, and beyond.
The growth mindset activities
are a chance for you
to make a lasting change
in students' lives,
and as they continue into adulthood,
which is so very important.
Lastly, the cherry on
the sundae, celebrating.
The biggest part of LearnStorm,
which has led to many
classroom celebrations,
is the LearnStorm tracker.
Here's how it works.
Access the LearnStorm tracker
from the LearnStorm banner
on your teacher coach dashboard.
Once you click on the blue button
you should be taken to your
class LearnStorm tracker.
We've included a demo for you
to see what it's all about.
As your students complete assignments
on Khan Academy which
are assigned to them,
the rings on the LearnStorm tracker
will populate and fill up.
Once your students have completed a set
of number of assignments
based on the number of
students in your class
the ring will fill up and
celebrations will occur.
This year there are a near
infinite number of rings
which means there are so
many moments for celebration,
encouragement, or perhaps
friendly competition
between a neighboring class (laughs).
Each ring is three-times the number
of students in your class.
Students get super excited
regardless of the age,
and we've even seen students
jump out of their seats in celebration.
For a limited time, LearnStorm,
(mumbling) LearnStorm, we
have growth mindset activities
that you can also assign to your class
to receive credit in
your LearnStorm tracker.
Alright, enough from me.
I am very excited to introduce our panel
who will tell us more
about growth mindset.
Alright, today we have Dave Paunesku
founding director of PERTS, a
center at Stanford University
that helps educators apply insights
from the behavioral
sciences to create safe
and engaging learning environments
that foster student
motivation and resilience.
Annie Brock, a former teacher,
and author of The Growth Mindset Coach,
a month-by-month guide of how
to implement mindset in your classroom.
And Samala Robinson, a
current fourth-grade teacher
in Independence, Missouri,
who has developed
many creative ways to help her
student's learning mindsets.
So, welcome to our panel.
So, my first question is for Dave.
Can you tell us more of
what is growth mindset?
- Yeah, so growth mindset is really
the belief that our abilities
and our intelligence
are something that we can
grow by applying effort
appropriately to the right
kinds of learning strategies.
And it's distinguished
usually from a fixed mindset,
which is the belief that our abilities
and our intelligence are fixed.
That they're something like eye color.
Something that we really
can't change about ourselves.
Now, it's important to
note that growth mindset
isn't the belief that everyone's the same,
or that everyone's equally intelligent,
or learns the same way.
Rather, it's a belief that
no matter how smart you are,
you can always become smarter
by learning from your mistakes
and challenging yourself to learn more.
- Very good.
I guess, this is a
question for Annie and Sam,
why is growth mindset
important for students?
- I think growth mindset is just
really essential for students
because so many students
come to school with us
feeling limitations,
whether they put them on themselves
or they've been put on by someone else.
And I think when students
develop growth mindsets
they start to understand that
their possibilities are limitless.
That with hard work and effort
they can make great
achievements in school.
There's a quote in Carol
Dweck's book Mindset.
That's, a person's true potential
is unknown and unknowable,
and it's impossible to foresee
what can be accomplished
with years of passion, toil, and training.
And that's like my
personal teaching mantra
because I wanna enter school every day
and just feel like I'm
not gonna limit any kid.
Any kid can achieve anything
if they wanna put in the work.
When you're a student, and
you go into the classroom,
and you look around, and
there's 20 or 25 other learners,
it's really easy to get in
that fixed mindset space
where you're looking
around and contemplating,
why does this come so quickly to her,
or why is he so great at
this, and it's so hard for me?
It's easy to tell yourself the story that,
oh, they're just blessed
with that ability,
or oh, they just have some natural talent
or natural affinity for math,
or art, or music, or whatever.
It's hard to reckon with the truth
that effort is what leads to achievement.
But we have to care
about our students enough
not to let them get away
with the easy thing,
which is just to believe that
they're not cut out for it.
I just think it's so important
to bring growth mindset
into our schools and into our classrooms
because when we give kids the tools,
the language of growth mindset,
the tools to use growth
mindset in their learning,
they learn how to put
in effort, to push hard,
to fight, to achieve goals,
and the kids who are achieving goals
will turn into adults who achieve goals,
and we need adults who are tenacious
and willing to solve difficult problems.
That starts in our classrooms.
- Yeah.
- I think the great thing
about growth mindset
is it gives every single child hope.
It's no longer this mindset of okay,
those are the kids who are smart,
and I'm never gonna be one of them.
Everyone is on a journey,
everyone can learn.
And Annie kinda touched on this,
at the beginning of the year I
describe knowledge to my kids
as a sphere to help 'em visualize it.
And there's an infinite number
of doors on this sphere,
and we've all got these keys,
and it can be so frustrating
to look over and watch your
friend put their key in,
and turn and the door opens,
yet when you put your
key in, it doesn't work.
That's not where we stop, though.
That's where you get with your teacher
and we are gonna figure this out.
We're gonna figure out how our brain works
and we're gonna keep going
because you deserve that moment
where you put your key in, and
all your effort has paid off,
and that door finally turns.
And the great thing about
the growth mindset is
embedded within it is goal
setting, it's reflection,
and we're truly empowering our kids
to be life-long learners, not
just fourth-grade learners.
- Right.
So, I guess for Annie and for Dave,
there's so much out there
about growth mindset.
What is important for
teachers to focus in on
when fostering a growth
mindset for students?
- Yeah, so I think a really great place
to start is by laying that foundation.
By helping them really understand
that the brain is malleable.
Really helping them understand
the neuroscience behind growth mindset.
So again, I think that's
really just the foundation.
So, that's a great place to start,
and I think the LearnStorm
growth mindset activities
really do a good job of
laying that foundation.
But then I think it's really important
to go deeper than that, too,
and I think what teachers
can do to do that is
to create this growth mindset culture,
which is characterized by
being really a safe place
for students to feel like
they can make mistakes,
and where they can challenge themselves
without worrying about how
their teacher will see them
or how their peers will see them.
It's a place where they'll feel like
their mistakes will be celebrated,
as long as they're learning from them,
and where growth is
prioritized over proficiency.
And I think what teachers can do
is they can really make it
obvious that in their class
the thing that matters most
is how much they're learning,
and that their relationship
with their students
isn't one of judge, but
rather one of coach.
So, a lot of the time students
worry that their teacher,
they really see their teacher as a judge,
someone who's there to evaluate
whether they're a good
learner or a bad learner,
whether they're smart or dumb,
but when they see their
teachers as a judge in that way,
it can really get in the way of learning
because it's very hard to be vulnerable
if you're really worried about
how the person will see
you, and to ask for help.
But in contrast, if a
teacher really creates
this kind of growth mindset culture,
and really talks to their students,
and helps them see them as their coach,
as someone who's really there
to bring out the best in them
and help them grow the most,
then that really changes
the way students feel about
challenging themselves,
and helps them feel
much more confident and comfortable.
Really putting themselves out there
and challenging themselves.
- I love that.
- Yeah, I agree with everything Dave said,
and I would also, number one,
is just teaching kids
what the mindsets are.
Giving them the
understanding of how learning
actually happens in their bodies.
How their brains work,
what equipment we all have.
That process of creating connections
in our brain is the same for everyone.
So, just giving them
that knowledge is key.
And then secondly, giving
them challenging work,
and that's gonna look
differently for every kid.
Challenging, there's many definitions
in a classroom of what
challenging work is,
but giving them challenging
work and then supporting them
as they meet the high expectations
that you've set for them,
in doing that, you're creating
a growth mindset culture
because truly, if the work is easy,
the mindset is irrelevant.
if kids are just breezing through things.
To me, a growth mindset classroom
looks like lots of chances
on your path to mastery.
Lots of chances to get it right.
A teacher who's modeling growth mindset,
so talking through the process,
talking through your struggles,
and valuing growth over perfection.
And I love how you talked
about normalizing mistakes,
or looking at mistakes as
an opportunity to learn.
I have a funny story.
I was chatting with some
Khan Academy ambassadors,
and a teacher said that she had taught
her second grade class about
what growth mindset was,
and they're working towards
looking at mistakes and failure
as just a part of learning.
You teach these things, and
you tell the kids these things,
and you're not sure if it's resonating
until it comes back to you in some form.
She said one kiddo who started the year
with a little bit of a fixed mindset
came in with some homemade signs that said
this is a mistake making place,
but making was spelled M-A-K-E-I-N-G.
- Oh.
- I know, that is such a good story.
I'm like, that's such a great example
of what growth mindset looks like.
It is trying, it's putting
yourself out there,
it's being vulnerable and I can't imagine
what kind of amazing
classroom that teacher has
where a kid internalizes that,
and then is willing to just show up
and put himself out there.
So, you can foster growth
mindset in your classroom
in a bunch of different
ways, but to me it looks like
what is growth mindset?
Giving challenging work,
setting high expectations,
and then being that support structure
for the kids to achieve their goals.
- Right. Well, thank you.
Thank you for sharing that story.
That sounds like a really amazing way
to foster learning in sort
of the best environment
that we want for all of our
students, which is so great.
Dave, I know that Khan
Academy worked with you a lot
on these growth mindset activities.
Can you give me some of the highlights
of the curriculum?
- Yeah, so it was really fun first of all
working on that curriculum
with the Khan Academy team,
I always enjoy that.
I think one thing I
really appreciate about it
is that it really, I
think, does a good job
of hitting a lot of the main
themes that are important
for laying that foundation
for a growth mindset,
and it does it in a really
fun and engaging way,
in no small part thanks to Thinky Pinky,
who's a great character to have
accompany you on this ride.
But yeah, it really hits at
some of the scientific evidence
behind the growth mindset,
and it really helps students understand
how powerful mistakes can be.
How they can really be allies
on this learning journey,
if you take time to
really reflect on them,
and really understand what that means,
what opportunities you
have to learn better
and to better develop.
It also helps students
set ambitious goals,
because if you're not
really challenging yourself
then it doesn't matter if
you have a growth mindset.
If you're just thinking,
boy, I sure could grow,
but if you're not doing things
that actually challenge
you to grow, you won't.
So, I think it helps
students set those goals,
and really understand why
doing that is important.
And then I think last, but not least,
and also when you're really doing that,
when you're going for
those ambitious goals
and pushing yourself,
you're gonna struggle,
and you're going to get
frustrated sometimes.
And there's also really good advice there
for students and for teachers
around how to deal with
those inevitable struggles that come up
when you're really pushing yourself.
- Right. Exactly.
I guess, Sam, just for those
teachers who are watching
who are like, I need some
practical applications
of how to do this, and
what's happening now,
you've participated in LearnStorm
for a couple years now.
What are you looking
forward to for LearnStorm
and the growth mindset
activities for this year?
- Well, I really like that
there's been a bit of a shift
in the LearnStorm in
that now they are aligned
to elementary, middle
school, and high school,
and I think that helps
a tremendous amount.
We spend so much time at
the beginning of the year
doing these direct lessons
where we're talking about
what's actually happening in your brain,
and what's happening in your
body when you become stressed,
and dealing with the
frustrations and everything.
We do all these different activities,
and then just at the perfect
time LearnStorm comes in,
and the kids get to hear that
information in a different way
and interact with it in a different way.
Although the growth mindset videos
and articles are phenomenal,
for me personally,
the best part about LearnStorm
is what happens right after that,
when the application piece comes in.
When we're doing math,
or coding, or grammar,
or whatever we're working on,
and they go to do their assignments,
and there's such a
presence of class synergy.
Because if you wanna see my class
suddenly get silent and excited,
my class manager, Maddy,
she'll go up to the
board and they watch her
like on pins and needles 'cause they know
she's getting ready to
push a check progress.
They want those rings to fill so badly,
and they know that
every single one of them
contributed to that happening.
I love, though, that Dave mentioned
dealing with the frustrations.
I had a student who just, she was like,
just tell me how to do this one.
She didn't want to do it on her own.
They know that I won't do that.
I'm here for you, let's talk through it.
Don't tell me what you don't know,
tell me what you do know,
and working through it,
and she left that day totally frustrated,
and came back the next day,
could not wait to grab her Chromebook.
Ran over, said she'd figured it out,
popped it in, and it was correct.
She was the class hero in that moment.
I asked her, I said, how
do you feel right now?
She's like, oh, I feel so good.
I did this.
I said, you wouldn't have felt like that
if I'd just told you the answer.
And so taking those little moments
to let your kids feel
that intrinsic motivation,
I think is really, really
powerful in the classroom,
and LearnStorm kind of gives us that
framework at the beginning
to really help establish that
that's what this is
like in this classroom.
- Right, that's amazing.
And can I just ask as like
an aside, as a teacher,
what is that moment like
for you to experience?
To see your students kind of
learn and experience that.
- There's a gamut of emotions
when you watch your kiddos learn
because you feel
frustrations along with them,
and you feel the discouragement, too.
I have a young man who really has,
he has a lot of intense emotions
that he's learning to deal
with, as a lot of our kids do.
He was so frustrated
because on an assignment
that we had did, he got one out of seven,
and he was just so down.
I was like, buddy, your
neurons found a path.
You got one, you know?
He was like, what?
Not very impressed with that response.
And I said, you know what?
We're gonna do this again.
I wanna see if you're neurons can find
another path and get
two, and he got three.
And then he said, go away.
(laughing)
Alright, so I went to help other kiddos,
and a little bit later he came to me,
and he said, I need
you to close your eyes.
Then he led me back to his computer,
and I open my eyes, and he had
tears running down his face,
and it said seven out of seven.
- [Rachel] Aw.
- And in that moment, like
that's why we're teachers,
and that's why we do what we do,
and that's what we strive for.
For him to feel that moment,
and know he did it on his own,
and he gave his brain the time to learn
and allow his neurons
to find those pathways.
And the other kids see that, too,
and it empowers them as much.
Like, I can do this, too.
Go away, go away. I got it.
(laughing)
So, there's a litany of emotions
you feel as a teacher, as well.
You feel the frustrations with them.
There's nothing better than
the kid, that they've got it.
- I love that.
It definitely seems, just
from hearing you all talk,
and then kind of our
earlier conversations,
that there's definitely
a certain sort of bravery
that has to happen on both
the side of the teacher
and the student when participating in
these growth mindset activities, right?
You have to trust that
your students can do this,
and that they can learn,
and that it's okay
to watch them struggle a little bit.
And then on the other
end, for these students,
it's okay for them to struggle,
and to work through things,
and I think that's such
a beautiful lesson.
Not just in class, but just in general.
So, this question we
have from Helen in Utah,
and I will throw this question
to Sam, and perhaps everyone.
With the demands on the time of day,
where do you fit in a
growth mindset activities,
and what is your favorite activity?
- So, at the beginning of the year
you do have to make time
to do direct lessons.
15, 25 minutes a day.
It can involve a mentor text
such a Ish, or Beautiful Oops,
or The Great Mistake, any of those.
Or it can be, my kids really like,
I actually will show them scans of brains
and we will talk about what's happening.
They learn about the neurons.
They learn about the parts of the brain
and what they're responsible for.
And it's a really powerful moment for them
because a lot of kids come
and they villainize themselves.
I'm not smart.
Whereas this give them, okay,
no this is what's happening in my brain,
and I can grow from this.
And so, we start with that platform,
and that does take direct instruction time
at the very beginning of the school year.
Probably a couple weeks.
And we try to do a lot of
activities along with them.
We will read Ish and
then paint on a canvas.
We make calm down jars
where the kids will put
glitter and beads in a jar,
and their favorite food coloring,
and talk about calming our brain.
We talk about how our
body releases stress,
cortisol when they're
stressed, and we can't think.
And so, we do a lot of these
activities at the beginning,
and really devote the time to it,
and I know we don't have
a lot of time as teachers,
but the payoff is tenfold.
From there it really is about embedding it
into just how you speak to your kids
and how you ask them to
speak not only to you,
but mostly to themselves.
My students have on their desk
a picture of themselves holding
a sign they created that says yet.
At the beginning, I gotta
point to that picture a lot
because they self-doubt, and they
talk so negatively to themselves.
And so, I can't do this,
and I'll point to it,
and say, I can't do it yet.
And then we work really hard to say,
okay, we can sit here
all day talking about
the things we don't know.
Let's start on this
problem, what do you know?
And it's more, it's not about something
you do separate from that point,
it's how you empower your students,
and how you talk to them,
and how you expect them
to talk to themselves.
That's really...
The rest of the year, it's
not something extra anymore.
It's just the environment
in your classroom,
your vocabulary, their vocabulary.
And I tell 'em, I will never let anybody
be mean to you, especially yourself.
And I think a lot of kiddos,
they're the meanest to themselves.
- Right.
- I agree with everything that Sam said.
I think in terms of concrete
activities that you can do,
definitely direct instruction for teaching
what is growth mindset, and giving them
that vocabulary, those tools.
Understanding how their brains work,
that requires some direct
instruction upfront,
but totally agree that if you do that
little front loading piece,
and then you work really hard to embed
growth mindset into your culture.
It's not necessarily a kind
of activity but it's...
For me, I think any type
of lesson or activity
that requires iterative
thinking, or trial and error
is going to allow them to
experience a little struggle,
experience testing something,
it works, it doesn't work,
and going back to the drawing board.
Any type of collaborative activities
are really great for
working with one another.
Project-based learning.
Where there's not
necessarily a right answer,
and just coming up with solutions.
The breakouts I think are really great,
or any opportunity for the kids
to have some productive struggle
when you create a challenge that
may be a little just
beyond their capabilities,
and let them grapple
with that a little bit.
Those are all good opportunities,
but they should just be things
that we're doing every day
that there's always chances,
and I always think that
the important piece
is that we debrief
afterwards, and we talk about
what was your learning like?
What did it feel like?
How did you push through
the difficult parts?
I think, as a learner, in my
experience as a learner anyway,
those most difficult experiences
are the most memorable experiences.
They're the ones that I
walk away like, I did it!
I got through that even if it ended up
being a C in algebra, to me,
when it felt like there was no hope,
walking out of there, and
knowing that I had gotten it,
or had grown, that's a
really rewarding experience.
So, just embedding it in the
culture of your classroom
and in everything you do is so important.
- Right.
Dave, anything to add?
- No, I think that's great.
- Okay. Sure.
I was gonna say one of
my favorite things about
what you both said is just the idea that
we can kind of have this
generation of students
who don't have to unlearn
these bad mentalities
about themselves, and internalize that.
What kind of young people
can we unleash on the world
if they were just super positive about
what they could accomplish?
It's so amazing. I love it.
Alright, Scarlett from Georgia asked,
what is the best way to get students
excited about growth mindset?
I will throw this one to Annie and Sam.
- I think to get kids
excited is number one,
just I think Sam was saying earlier,
I'm gonna steal what
we were talking about,
but Sam was saying earlier
that kids come to you
already feeling excited
about their potential.
Or if they come to you feeling
down about their potential,
if you could teach them about
how their brains work, and
how with effort and hard work
they can make accomplishments
and make gains in their learning,
that gets them excited,
especially when they see progress.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be like a party
to get excited about it.
I think we all are excited
about our own potential.
And when you bring that
passion into the classroom
and you're developing
relationships with the kids,
and growing those bonds,
and showing them that
you believe in their capabilities,
teaching them how to believe in themselves
and how to reframe and refocus,
how to be mindful about
how they learn best and
apply those strategies,
and give them opportunities to struggle
and come out on top, I
think kids get excited about
learning and about their own
possibilities and capabilities.
- Yeah, I think so.
And as adults sometimes,
we haven't put ourselves
in situations in a while often
that kids are in every day.
Where we are struggling,
and we don't get something,
and we want to get it.
If you've forgotten what that feels like,
then I encourage you to go take a class,
or do something outside the normal
because there's not a
worse feeling in the world
than seeing everybody else get it,
and you giving it your
all, but you don't get it.
And so, growth mindset
empowers kids to know that
that's not the period, that's
not the end of the story.
- [Rachel] Right, right, exactly.
- And that doesn't define me.
This is a part of my
journey, and watch me go.
- [Rachel] Right.
- I think modeling and sharing.
There's lots of teachers have success
with sharing stories of famous failures.
Michael Jordan was cut from his
high school basketball team,
or Harry Potter was rejected 10 times,
or Abraham Lincoln lost his first bid
for the Illinois House of Representatives,
or whatever it is.
Sharing those stories,
and letting kids know,
nobody has a seamless
upward trajectory in life.
We all have this kind of
rocky path that we take.
There's ups and downs, and
the journey towards success
requires a lot of that.
I think that gets them excited, too.
- [Rachel] Exactly.
- I think fail with your kids, you know?
A lot of schools now are
doing failure Fridays,
and I love failure Fridays.
The teacher too, we're all learners,
and we're gonna try something
completely out of the norm for 15 minutes.
We're gonna juggle.
We're going to try to cook something.
We're going to paint.
We're gonna try to just do
all sorts of various things
that might be outside the norm,
and demonstrate to them that
you can't do it right away
either, and you know what?
Congratulations, we failed.
Now what?
- Right.
I love that part.
Like, the now what part?
That's very, very encouraging.
I'm gonna remember that when I fail at
many of the things I try.
Yes, go ahead.
- I was just gonna say that
I know that some teachers
will actually make a point to
intentionally make mistakes
in front of their students so that
they can really model for them
when their students call them out and say,
hey, that was a mistake,
they can model for them
the really adaptive response with that.
Say, oh yeah, you're
right, that was a mistake.
Help me fix that.
What did I do wrong?
And that could really be
this kind of magical time
when teachers can be
vulnerable for their students
and really model that it's
okay to make mistakes,
and that the important
thing is to really learn
from each other and learn
from those mistakes.
- Right.
Yeah, I think that's very true
'cause I think a lot of teachers feel that
they have to kind of be kind of perfect,
and the front of the classroom,
and they want to project this image.
I think students learn so much better
when they have someone to relate to,
and they're like, oh I see someone that
I can kind of grow towards,
which is really great.
I have a question from Sarah
from Bonnie Brae, Virginia.
Sarah asked, how can I best support
a learner with disabilities
like ADHD, Asperger's,
and so on, with concrete examples,
scaffolding in growth mindset?
That's a really great question.
I'm gonna throw it out to the whole panel
to answer that question.
- I think any kid can understand
the basics of how we learn
and what growth mindset is.
I mean, I've seen as young as preschoolers
understand that concept
of what growth mindset is,
and how learning happens in our bodies.
And once you start with that foundation,
I think it's just really important to
let kids know that learning is a journey,
and the journey is
different for every person.
Growth mindset is not trying
hard and winning every time.
People sometimes have that
idea that that's what it is.
Being successful and getting
success or achievements
look different for every person.
I mean, I got an email from a lady
after I wrote a book on growth mindset,
and she said, well, I have a friend
and she struggles with
a learning disability,
and it took her four times
to pass algebra class,
and so growth mindset doesn't work.
I said, well she passed it, you know?
It just took four times.
- Right.
- And really, it's about us changing
what our definition of success looks like
because for a lot of teachers
it's just getting an A+ is success.
For a lot of parents,
getting an A equals success.
But we have to look at
it in a different way.
Sometimes, it's starting with a 32%
and ending up with a 75%.
Getting one right, and
then keep working at it
until you get seven right.
It's a process, and I think no matter,
my own son struggles with reading
and we walk about the way
that you learn reading
is gonna be different from other people.
It might take you a
little longer to get it.
You might have to employ
some different strategies
that other kids don't have
to do, but you'll get there.
It's just this is your
road, this is your path,
and you have to embrace that.
- Right.
Dave, anything to add?
- No, that was great. Yeah.
- Annie, sorry.
- I love everything she said.
(laughing)
One of my students after a lesson one day,
made a comment, Daisy.
She said that even if...
She redefined the way she
was thinking, and she goes,
I'm not gonna think about
losing the same way anymore.
I said, tell me more about that.
What do you mean?
She goes, if I lose, but I look at
why do I think I lost, and what
could I do better next time?
She goes, I'm gonna start
counting that half winning.
(laughing)
I thought that was wonderful.
In my class, we've kind of adopted that.
And I love what you said about
we kind of redefine success.
It may not look like, okay,
it's 100% on the spelling test every time.
It's about growth for every child.
Where are you and where do you want to be?
It's about putting that goal
setting and that reflection in,
and every child moving forward, you know?
No matter where they are.
- That's fantastic.
We have a question from Michele
from Juniper, California.
What is the best way
to get parents on board
with the idea of growth mindset?
This is such a really important question
because I think growth mindset
can look very different
for many parents who may
not have seen it before,
and may not have heard it before.
So, how do you get them on board for this?
- I can start with one thought.
I think exactly.
I think for a lot of parents
it really is very different
than what they're used to,
and they might not understand,
is my kid's teacher just
making up all this new stuff?
'Cause it looks totally
different than what I'm used to.
And it might be very alien,
and so I think a good place to start
might be really with just explaining
all the research behind growth mindset.
I mean, not only that this
is true about our brains,
but also, what an
empowering impact that has
on a kid's motivation.
How kids, once they learn to
internalize the growth mindset,
how they really end up being
much more likely to challenge themselves,
to learn from their mistakes,
to take more challenging classes,
to do well in class, right?
So, the end of the day it's really
an evidence-based approach to
building student's motivation,
and ultimately, their achievement, too.
So, I think even parents
who are really sticklers
for at the end of the day I
want my kid to learn the most,
well, if that's what you want,
then this is actually how you get there.
It's by removing the fear from learning
that might otherwise constrain them.
And growth mindset and
growth mindset cultures
can really just do such a fantastic job
of helping kids really feel empowered
and unleashed to learn at their best,
and to really seem themselves growing,
rather than being afraid of doing poorly.
I think that's a great starting point,
and then I know these two have
some great follow up suggestion.
- We have to look at home as an extension
of the classroom, and vice versa.
I think just giving parents the tools
to understand what growth mindset is,
why we do it, it's an
evidence-based approach,
and then teaching them
strategies to help them.
And a lot of times, that comes down to
just talking to your kids.
There's kind of the old cliche.
Like, you ask your kid,
what'd you do today at school?
Nothing.
How was it?
Fine.
You know, you always hear that.
But if parents can be intentional about
how they talk to their kids after school,
I always ask, my kids and
I, we have a running thing,
so every day after school, I
say best, worst and weirdest.
So, they have to tell me my best thing,
their worst thing, and
their weirdest thing,
which ends up with a lot of funny stories,
but it also gives us an
opportunity to kind of dive into,
okay, so something didn't go very well.
Why not?
What was the catalyst
for that not going well?
Or if something went great,
what kind of strategies
did you use to pull that off?
I mean, how did you prepare?
How did you study?
How did you handle that tricky situation
on the playground, or whatever?
But talking to your kids instead of just,
good job, A on the test,
ask them, how did you prepare for this?
What kind of learning went into this?
Likewise, if they didn't do so well,
let's talk about what happened.
So really helping parents
build that communication
with their kids about
strategies for learning,
and what works, and what doesn't,
and having them draw the link between
effort and achievement is really important
so that kids are hearing
it everywhere they go.
- Very good.
Best, worst, weirdest.
I love that.
(laughing)
Super cool.
Annie?
I'm sorry, Sam?
- That's alright.
I think the bottom line too,
when it comes to parents is
they are sending us the most
precious gift they have,
and there is nothing
worse of a feeling than
being a parent and seeing your
child struggle in reading,
or struggle in math,
and you want so badly to
fix it for them, but you don't know how.
And so sometimes, when
these parents come to us
and they're frustrated and
they just want it fixed,
they're coming from a place of love.
We have to train them, too,
'cause they'll come upset.
My child is not a good reader,
or my child's not good at math.
Well now, and yet.
- [Rachel] Right.
- So, what are we gonna do?
If you really want to
see the kids just go far,
a strong partnership between the kiddo,
the teacher and the parent,
you've got a big support
system there to really hold up.
And then it comes down to
what Annie was talking about earlier.
Alright, we got our
support system holding you.
Now let's go for some effort.
- Right, right. Exactly.
That sounds like a really
strong kind of foundation
when you have that.
That sounds beautiful.
We have a question from Alyssa B.
How would you recommend
facilitating and encouraging
other faculty to promote growth mindset?
So, this is a good question of like,
what do you do in your
actual school environment?
- I think being transparent
and being vulnerable.
Teachers work really hard,
and we do not have a
lot of time in the day.
Sometimes it's really easy
to hear something and think,
that's just another thing.
So I think by being transparent
and allowing people to
come into your classroom
or see the fruits of your kids' labor.
Let your kids lead things.
Let your kids be the ones who
go out and talk about things
because that's where the power lies
and that's where you show that
these mountains are being moved.
And then I think, also, being vulnerable.
Being able to go to a meeting and say,
guys, I'm really working
on growth mindset,
but I really feel like I
personally am failing here.
I need some help.
And having those open discussions
I think encourage more people.
We talk about our students feeling safe,
but it's the same thing with the staff.
The teachers, we've got to feel safe, too,
to kind of embark on this
because it's uncomfortable
at the beginning,
and it's a new way of
thinking, and speaking,
and there's a big power shift
from the teacher to the kiddos
and that's nerve-wracking
at the beginning.
- [Rachel] Right.
- It's such a positive power shift,
but scary to take at the beginning.
- [Rachel] Right.
- Getting administrators in on it, too.
I really believe that just
like people approach things
with a growth and fixed
mindset, that a school has,
organizations have a
growth or fixed mindset.
A lot of times, you don't
have to look further than
the handbook to figure out
what are we valuing here?
Are we valuing growth?
Are we valuing perfection?
So, getting a good gauge on
what is being valued and how,
are only the kids who are
getting on the A honor role,
are they the ones that
are being celebrated?
Do we have ways of celebrating kids
who are making less,
or making incremental steps toward growth?
Do we celebrate that
at all in our culture?
And so as a teacher, I think
you have the opportunity
to speak to your admins and say,
we need to refocus and celebrate.
Like Dave said, this is
evidence, this is research-based.
There's a strong body of
research going back, what?
30 or 40 years.
- [Dave] Very long time. Yeah.
- That supports this as a
valuable learning intervention.
And just sharing that and being
an advocate for it in
your school, I think,
is key to changing the
culture of the entire school.
- Right.
Very good.
- Yeah, the only thing
I would add is just that
when I've talked to teachers
who have kind of catalyzed
these kinds of cultural
transformations in their schools,
I think a lot of the
times it's really happened
with just a handful of teachers
who really started doing it,
and they really started modeling it,
and going and talking to
other teachers about it.
It took some time.
It wasn't like a we're all gonna do
growth mindset all at once.
I think in my experience,
that usually doesn't work very well.
It's usually more that
you kind of start around
this kind of core,
crystal group of teachers,
and then it kind of
branches off from there.
And as other teachers can see
the kind of amazing things
that can happen, and
then they start to say,
hey, maybe that could work in my class.
Actually, I'd like to have my kids be
that inspired or that motivated.
- That's interesting.
That's very interesting.
Actually, I'm very curious to know.
For Sam, what made you want to try out
these growth mindset activities?
What was the catalyst for that?
- It actually stemmed
in the beginning it was,
I noticed that my kiddos
were coming without tools.
At the time, I was in fifth grade
and I had to send my babies
off to middle school,
and I wanted them as empowered
and with as many strategies
as they could possibly have
before they went because middle school
could be really difficult years.
And so, I started looking at
things like their perseverance,
how did they speak to one another?
How did they advocate for themselves
when they need something?
We started little by little
looking at things like that,
and I started really kind
of trying to research
and find things to support that.
It's funny, we watched, at
the beginning of the year
I show my kids a video of a
really famous quantum theorist.
He's melded science and math,
and he's been working on the
same equation now for 12 years.
And I promise my kids,
I will never make you
work on an equation for 12 years.
But if he can do 12 years,
we can do 20 minutes.
(laughing)
We started trying to build that stamina,
and then it just kind of grew from there,
and it was kind of the perfect timing.
Annie's book came out.
Carol Dweck's book was coming out.
PERTS is really on the stage now.
LearnStorm's out, and it
was just it feels like
a lot of us were seeking this,
if you look at the manifestation of
what has really come to the surface.
So, I think a lot of
teachers at the same time
really were feeling the same need.
- Right. That's beautiful.
Alright, I'm glad we
could help fill that need.
That makes me feel good.
Leigh Ann Morgan from Ontario asked,
are there words and
phrases that foster growth
that I can include in my
student conversations?
I think actually all of you
have touched upon this idea of vocabulary,
so let's see if we can
try to touch on that.
- I'm a firm advocate of the power of yet.
Any time they say any
kind of negative talk,
I'll point to them, yet.
(laughing)
And then they have to say it.
And then we're big on our, hey, now what?
Or great, what do you need?
We practice a lot at the
beginning of the year
building a toolkit of okay,
I'm stuck now, so what?
Alright, I can ask for more time.
I can ask to hear it in a different way.
I can ask the teacher to rephrase it.
I can ask.
We talk about what are different things
I can do to advocate for myself?
Because I might not always
be within these four walls
when I encounter a problem,
and I need to have those intrinsic skills.
Having that vocabulary
ready for your kids,
and then on the teacher's part,
really trying to back away
from good job, that's right.
- [Rachel] Mm-hmm. Right.
- Leave it to the class.
Mathematicians, what do you think?
This mathematician has proposed this idea.
Thoughts?
You know?
At the beginning, they
just stare at you like,
is it right or wrong, you know?
But they start to learn,
and it's so powerful,
and it is so hard as a teacher, though,
when somebody throws something
wildly incorrect out there.
But the cool thing is, is
there's a lot of grace in that,
too, because when the
kids start debating it
and discussing it, we talk about
do you have the right to change your mind?
And the kid'll say, oh, I'd
like to change my answer.
And I think there's so much power in
how kids speak to each other
and speak to themselves.
It's hard for the teacher
kind of backing up
and just giving those launch points,
those launching questions, and then
you're crowd control at that point.
- [Rachel] Right. Very good.
- I think just being
mindful of person praise
versus process praise.
If we say to a kid who does really well,
oh, you're so smart, they equate
doing well with being smart.
That it's some inherent,
inborn thing that they have
that they can do well.
And then when inevitably
they hit a setback,
which they will, and
they don't do so well,
then all of a sudden
it's like a question of,
well if I'm not smart, then who am I?
So, just being mindful of praising effort
and the process that they took to learn,
like that was a really
great strategy you used,
or I like how you solved that problem.
Or if they breeze through something
maybe that wasn't challenging enough.
Let's try to find something else.
So, being mindful of that.
Being more robust with your feedback.
I think we like to use stickers
and say good job a lot.
In the book I wrote, we call it,
well, I read it somewhere else,
but they call it Paula Praise.
So, on American Idol, if you
think back to American Idol,
like the first with Simon,
and Paula and Randy,
Paula would always say, good job!
(speech drowned out by laughter)
And Simon was a lot meaner,
but he was much more specific.
And so, you don't want to be like that,
but definitely be specific in the feedback
that you're giving.
I would rather have less
feedback that's more specific
than generalized praise
that is really meaningless.
So, you want to be mindful of that,
and then yeah, just thinking about that,
I used to say, come on, you can do this.
It's so easy.
That was something I said as a teacher,
and I look back and think, oh my gosh.
You know what?
That wasn't easy for that person.
- [Rachel] Right.
- It was easy for me, or
I thought it was easy,
but it wasn't easy for that person,
and so what I was saying
was actually not helping.
It was counterproductive.
And I thought I was being helpful.
So, just really be mindful
of what you're saying
and how that affects the
student that you're working with
is really important.
- Yeah, and I really
love all those points.
Yeah, I guess just from a
growth mindset standpoint,
I think the kinds of language we use,
the kinds of words we use is
gonna be really important,
and there are, so for example,
are you referring to
things as, for example,
we can talk about building skills.
Like, really calling out
when you're doing something
of why are you doing it?
Oh, you're building your skills.
You're becoming a mathematician.
You're building your
writing skills right now,
or you're becoming a better writer.
Really focusing students
on those processes,
and then kind of how the
fact that they're learning
while they're doing, so kinda taking,
again, taking the focus
off of the end result,
and really focusing it on the thing
that students can actually
control for themselves,
which is the process that they're doing.
And really reminding them and
kind of debriefing with them
so that they really understand
what it is that they're doing,
and that all this effort
that they're doing,
it's not just going into a grade.
It's going to them leveling up.
Them becoming a writer, them
becoming a mathematician,
or a scientist, or whatever that may be.
A great civic thinker.
(laughing)
Whatever that may be, they're
really developing those skills
and really making sure to call out that
that learning process that
they're enacting in your class.
- Right, so not just work
for the sake of work,
but work for the sake of--
- Of growth.
- Of growth and betterment.
I love that.
Alright, so we're gonna wrap up.
I'm going to actually throw
you a bit of a curve ball
and ask you a final question,
but with a challenge.
So, what is one last piece
of advice for teachers
for fostering growth mindset
that you would give this year
if you can give it in 10 words or less?
(laughing) I know.
Alright, I'm gonna start with Dave.
- Have a growth mindset about
building a growth mindset culture.
Is that too much?
- I think I did that right.
(laughing)
Alright, go ahead Annie.
One last piece of advice for teachers.
- I would say model your
growth and fixed mindsets,
and normalize mistakes in your classroom.
(laughing)
- Well done, well done.
- [Annie] Thank you.
- I like it.
Alright, Sam, your last turn.
- Okay.
Be vulnerable.
- [Rachel] Mm-hmm.
- Be a champion for your kids, and model.
- [Rachel] I love that.
- Okay.
- That was very good,
and all very tweetable.
Very great.
(laughing)
So, I want to thank
Dave, and Annie, and Sam
for joining us today.
I learned something and I
hope that you all did, too.
I want to remind everyone that
there's still time to sign up,
so if you haven't signed up,
please sign up right now, today,
but definitely by the end of October.
And if you keep on tagging
your classroom celebrations
with #learnstorm on Twitter and Facebook,
we really love seeing it in the office,
so please keep on doing that.
Welcome back to the
school years, teachers.
Thank you, and goodbye.